professional wrestler turned actor john
cena accused of making a groveling
pathetic apology to china cena has been
out there promoting his new movie fast
and furious nine to international
markets
when he referred to taiwan as being the
quote first
country to watch the film the chinese
government was not happy with that
reference to taiwan as a
independent country so cena quickly
apologized in mandarin
cena says he's very sorry about his
mistake and that he really loves
and respects china so greg did a
a wrestling star just get body slammed
by china
i don't know i think what cena did was
cowardly and despicable and if i ever
see him face to face
i'll be sure and tell him the exact
opposite
i had no idea there were nine fast and
furious
i think i might be in one of them there
are that many but it's like look
it just shows you how in bed our
corporate
overlords are with a totalitarian regime
that didn't get arguably
the toughest actor in hollywood to offer
a groveling apology in mandarin
the only upside to this is i don't see
cena running around crapping on america
and apologizing to china like lebron
james
so katie obviously china thinks that
taiwan
belongs to them it's not an independent
country
but we the united states we have a one
china policy
uh so should we change and say that you
know what
taiwan we respect your independence and
sovereignty
taiwan is a country hong kong used to be
a sovereign it's been taken over by the
chinese communist
party the chinese the ctp is now engaged
in a genocide against an entire muslim
population
and what that means for america is we're
screwed because they don't even have to
try
to infiltrate american society and
culture when you have people
willing to put their profits from a
communist regime
in a country that treats people very
poorly or they don't have freedom to
access the kind of
information to tell them that taiwan is
an independent country
and it impacts every aspect of american
life whether it's the things that we buy
whether it's our pharmaceuticals coming
from china all of our ppe
and then of course hollywood now with
our culture they don't even have to try
or fire a shot they've already
infiltrated
every aspect of american society and
that does not bode well for the future
of our country
dana uh to katie's point if the film's
not shown in china
the producers and the stars will lose
millions if not
billions how would you handle this well
i think they should have thought of that
before
and i think this was pitiful it is not
attractive let me just tell you
i don't find that attractive at all i
think being bold is attractive
and what he's basically doing
is groveling and the thing that people
like saying i need to understand is that
do you know what the chinese then do
with a video like that
they use it as absolute propaganda right
and it is not right it speaks be bold
how much more money do you need
like be bold stand up taiwan deserves
our respect and our pledge of allegiance
to them
now let me tell you another thing though
do you remember in 2016
right after the election who was the
first
head of state for president trump to
call
called taiwan that's bold
and remember that it was a huge thing oh
my gosh how could he possibly do this
well you know what because he was
sending a message
and now maybe maybe like his team didn't
know exactly like oh gosh you know
going back decades the uh foreign policy
establishment in washington has very
strong feelings and the chinese get
really mad
well but they didn't care that i think
is really bold
so jesse uh the movie's gonna come out
it's
you know obviously pandemic over movie
theaters are gonna be filled when it
hits the u.s
are we gonna forget about this in a week
or two we will
and you know my policy juan i don't
attack people that can beat me up
and that policy has worked out very
favorably so i'm going to side with cena
here
the u.s government does not even
recognize an independent taiwan
so we expect him to i mean this is one
china policy it's been policy in the u.s
government both sides
since 79. we just sell these guys
defensive weapons
to keep the peace so if i'm getting paid
10 mil for this franchise by the studio
and they opened in china box office last
weekend for about like 140 million
and i like you know make a little gaffe
about an island
that they're prickly about i'm gonna say
hey my bad i'm sorry
it's not an island it's good business
come on and
no it's good manners we're talking about
the territorial integrity of the country
say that and also save the world
yes you're not saving the world check
this out world saved
so and you'll figure it out when you
read it but this isn't about
human rights this is about the
territorial integrity of the country
i can do nuance that is nuance and i can
do nuance dana
and i saw it with cena because he could
beat me up he can beat me up katie he
can beat me up
up next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else